the name of The Botch the first
experation of The Botch was Abigail
Bailey and the title was AI principal
head teacher what it was meant to do was
to help with leadership structure
thoughts and help me at strange times
when other people weren't working that
would be annoying if I called them up at
9:00 at night and uh help me structure
my thoughts about strategic leadership
at cotmore
how we're doing things at cmore is that
it's all in addition to the people who
are here in fact we have never employed
so many people uh so many humans uh as
we do now um and so we've got a lot of
people here so these Bots uh and this
strategic leadership bot and the head of
AI bot and the uh and and the other the
other Bots that are helping people they
are there to augment the the offering
they're not there to take away from
anybody or to um replace anybody and
they haven't and but they definitely are
um looking like they're helping a
lot yeah so um I I I assume in the US
but certainly in the UK uh teachers are
writing policies the whole time they're
writing risk assessments they're writing
schemes of work they're writing lesson
plans and these are the things that
could be uh the time could be reduced so
so much let's say you're writing a
scheme of work scheme of work is a whole
term or a long period of time when
you're teaching and um what happens is
you want to include some really
important government document in it and
so you go this is my scheme of work I
really need to include this safeguarding
document in it could you please uh
integrate that into all of my schemes of
work and also this can can work with
lesson plans and it will do it
seamlessly one of the coolest one of the
most exciting things that's happening
and we're developing it uh with a an AI
developer is um the idea of a bespoke uh
learning uh platform or bespoke learning
program for individuals and so you learn
about how each child learns and you get
that uh information and you feed it into
the AI and will produce individual
booklets or individual resources for the
specific child sitting in front of you
so there might be 20 children in the
room and there'll be 20 different
booklets that will be produced and they
will all have the things that they're
interested in let's say it's a math
thing and they'll have the uh thing that
they're interested in uh and the next
person will have another thing they're
interested in and that'll be related to
the maths and so it is specific to the
child and that is something that is
we're working very very very hard
on